j.j berea is on the floor here for
the dallas mavericks that was unexpected
rather than the aforementioned
burke the kings ratchet up the defensive
intensity
after giving up as katie mentioned so
many points in the first quarter
not you two off the rim gets the put
back offensive rebound and a second
chance but movement of bodies and the
movement of balls
creates uh wide open shots for your
teammates and the king shoot wide open
shots at a higher look
great just looking over the top right
there some
a lot of different things obviously
bones you can
do a little something to the capsule
there it can be very irritating not too
much of a problem no with a little
floater by lucas his chest but
so many times first we're gonna see luca
right here just understanding navigating
grabbing with the off hand
and then just a nice little pull-up
floater uh the kids got games
listed at 290 pounds 290
290 oh look at look it is a foul on alex
that is unnecessary
levo with a hand off in the drive by
doncic he does such a good job of
protecting with the left side of his
body scoring with the right
see him right here as you're talking
about it yep he he protects
takes the shoulder right up into the
chest of lynn
boom contact creates a little bit of
space
i like the pass and and cut option for
both don
because he's a crafty player a corner
pocket right there by justin jackson
former king justin jackson
[Applause]
orion finney smith misses at the rim oh
put back however
kick out step in two comes up short
back tap however to the maverick second
chance luca for the triple
scores it he ends up with a chance to
shoot a couple
looking nice and easy reach up hop right
into it and says
thank you
porzingis with a shake he loves that
move yeah he does he is really good at
converting
that bank shot on home staying down we
see luca right here drop it inside and
just a
quick little hesitation move and i mean
he's looking right over the hand of
harris paul comes right back to him and
he
drives to the basket fox now has 20.
luca answers he's got 21.
many good things in the community he has
the bobby jackson foundation that does
some wonderful things and that
that was a fabulous day marching uh
he the vac the kings
third foul on harry giles porzingis has
four oh that's a great cut a great
delivery right there
doncic now with 23
points 10 rebounds for a double double
four assists away from a
triple double the home runs we will take
singles doubles
walks doesn't matter g man
look at breaking down the defense draws
the foul converts
gets the three-point opportunity yeah
this is a tough one right here and i
would tell hg listen if you're if you're
going to foul and follow
you know don't let him don't let him
score the bucket i mean this is just a
strong
move takes the bump and he's going in
and as soon as you feel the fact that
you're going to foul him go ahead on the
radio with mark boyle in indiana that's
his trademark call
boom baby luca for three oh boy
i wondered when we were going to see him
start to launch out there have now had
their
12th free throw attempt which pales in
comparison to the 36
attempted by dallas corner three is
knocked down by dorian finney smith and
we're right back
to a three-point ball game terrific move
but no hoop to show for it
doncic draws the foul and converts and
he'll have a chance to tie this ball
game up
put their foot on the neck of an
opponent and really start to extend it
and
luca understands contact as soon as he
feels it
makes sure that he gets a real good look
at the back put it
in play can't fall asleep here because
he can pass the bad off
wow talk about falling asleep initial
drought
oh might want to stay with him beautiful
pass what a decision there's the triple
double yes
there's the triple double for donchi
create some movement
good call right there coach
[Applause]
give his heart away splash there's
doncic
[Music]
stay close quick help quick health quick
help
got to come hell and look at him use his
body and he converts inside
he's drew first blood in overtime but
now trail by two
liba for three and dallas has its
biggest lead of
the ball game